(box hits the floor)
(sigh)
(upbeat music)
- Hey Dad, can you transfer
me some some money?
- [Voiceover] Nick, you've
got a full-time job.
(upbeat music)
- Seamus, did you use my
prescription toothpaste?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, choose bro.
- No, it's... it's mine,
it's (beep)-ing expensive.
Get your own. (beep)
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] If I'm gonna give you money,
I want to know what it's for.
- I need to buy toilet paper.
- [Voiceover] Toilet paper?
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] How do you
not have toilet paper?
- I've just gotten by without it.
- [Voiceover] How is that possible?
- Because, I've been
holding in my poos for work.
(vacuum whirs)
(crash)
(vacuum whirs fade away)
- Hey Nick, my cousin's are
visiting Sydney this weekend.
Do you reckon we could
have a party at yours?
- Or, you can throw your own party.
- My parents are being dickheads about it.
- Alright. Fine. Okay, I'll have it.
- You're the best.
- One more thing, one more thing. Ummm....
Can you pay my rent this week?
(dial tone)
- Dad, Dad,
Hello?
(click)
- Wassaa!
- [Voiceover] Nick, what
are you doing? Get out!
- Let's play FIFA, let's play FIFA, Brad.
Please, I want to sleep.
- [Voiceover] Close the door.
- I'm sleeping here.
(upbeat music)
- (bleep) I'm old.